aujourd'hui nous avons eu donc notre
troisième rencontre cette année nos
liens personnels et 3 permettent de
résoudre un certain nombre de problèmes
en direct rapidement et de se mettre
d'accord sur les approches communes sur
le problème concerné
donc nous avons traité de la situation
extrêmement tendue dans la province
d'idleb
au début de cette année les formations
armées ont renforcé leurs activités sur
place et ont bombardé tant les positions
de l'armée syrienne que les localités et
la population civile
il ya eu des attaques sur la base russe
de rim et il ya eu plusieurs tentatives
de systèmes antiaériens de repousser ces
attaques
ces attaques ont été au nombre de 15 sur
une même depuis le début de l'année et
deux depuis le début de l'année nous
informant régulièrement en temps et en
heure nos partenaires sur donc les
combats ont repris et malheureusement il
y à des pertes du côté turc est à cet
égard
encore une fois j'ai exprimé mes
condoléances au président à monsieur le
président et je sais qu'il est très
préoccupé par cette situation et à
l'ensemble du peuple turc pour tous ses
blessés et c'est mort nous ne sommes pas
toujours d'accord avec nos partenaires
turcs dans leur appréciation de la
situation sur le terrain mais à chaque
fois les moments critiques
en s'appuyant sur les accords et sur les
relations que nous avons nous avons
toujours réussi à trouver des points
d'accord des points de convergence et et
notamment pour prendre des décisions qui
soient acceptables
c'est ce qui s'est passé cette fois-ci
encore aujourd'hui nous avons confirmé
notre un autre intérêt poursuivre ce
travail deux concerts et notamment dans
le cadre du format d'astana qui a prouvé
son efficacité dans le cadre du
règlement syrien au cours de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
réunions de consultation et de travail
ce ont été organisées autour la
situation à idleb nous partons du
principe qu'il faut respecter la
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
de la syrie et nous sommes aussi
convaincus qu'il ne faut pas affaiblir
la lutte contre le terrorisme
international
en conclusion de ces discussions nous
avons validé un document en commun et
qui est ratifié par les ministres des
affaires étrangères et qui stipule les
décisions que nous avons convenu avec
monsieur le président erdogan au cours
de cette réunion qui aujourd'hui a duré
plus de six heures nous manifestons
l'espoir que cet accord servira de base
pour une solution de règlement dans la
situation à la situation d'idleb et
réduire les souffrances de la population
civile et de façon à résoudre la crise
humanitaire que cela permettra de
revenir les conditions à un retour à la
paix pour l'ensemble des parties
impliquées dans le conflit en syrie je
tiens à remercier le président sûr que
d'avoir accepté de venir aujourd'hui de
confirmer le niveau de relation et je
remercie tous nos collègues turcs pour
ce travail constructif tendu et qui à
mon avis a donné un résultat positif je
vous remercie
l'objectif est que je voudrais également
remercier monsieur le président
messieurs les représentants des médias
mesdames messieurs selon nous je salue
chaleureusement et que j'exerce mon
métier je voudrais tout d'abord exprimer
ma reconnaissance pour l'invitation de
monsieur poutine au moment où la
situation dans notre région est très
tendue je suis ravi que nous avons
organisé cette réunion avec monsieur
poutine au cours de cette réunion nous
avons parlé en détail des problèmes en
syrie et de la situation actuelle à
idleb
comme monsieur poutine l'a déjà dit nous
avons à travailler pendant plus de six
heures pour résoudre ces problèmes mais
je voudrais souligner à cet égard que
notre dialogue est fondée sur une base
solide et nous avons parlé très
franchement monsieur le président je
peux dire que les relations entre la
russie à la turque ont des racines très
profondes
plus de 100 siècles de relations lie nos
deux pays il ya des traditions de
coopération entre nos deux pays
et bien sûr nous espérons de continuer
notre coopération
cette année nous fêtons la 100e le 100e
anniversaire de nos relations
diplomatiques et nous avons invité
monsieur poutine en turquie à cette
occasion
vous savez que en septembre nous avons
parvenu avec monsieur poutine
on me random de cette chine et se
noueront d'hommes a permis de parvenir à
une stabilité à idleb
ce mémorandum prévoyez la baisse des
tensions à idleb et la prévention des
attaques dans cette région
mais récemment nous avons vu des
attaques de plus en plus réguliers et
cela va à l'encontre de ce traité cet
accord les forces qui ont violé ces
accords sont responsables dans cette
région il ya quatre millions habitants
et on ne peut pas dire que c'est 4
millions sont terroristes
on ne peut pas bombarder ses 4000 ans
habitant les réfugiés doivent quitter
leur région leur pays selon l'onu
il y a environ 1 1 million 500 personnes
qui ont quitté idleb
certains veulent créer une situation
difficile pour la turquie parce que la
turquie devra faire face en nouveau flot
de réfugiés mais la turquie va réagir
face à cette situation tendue nous avons
créé des points de surveillance qui
devaient contrôler le cessez le feu au
lieu de contrôler la situation en
général et récemment nous avons parvenu
à un accord avec la russie pour envoyer
des forces supplémentaires afin de
stabiliser la situation dans la région
d'une part pour répondre riposter à des
attaques et d'autre part à résoudre la
situation dans la région
nous avons fait beaucoup d'efforts à
nous avons coordonner nos actions avec
la russie nous avons vu ces attaques de
la part du régime ce qui a causé des
événements tragiques et à cause de cela
nous avons dû créer un nouveau statut
pour il est aujourd'hui à moscou avec
nos collègues russes nous avons parlé en
détail de cette question la coopération
entre nos deux pays a entre la russie et
la turquie
c'est une coopération qui a apporté une
contribution sans précédent pour
résoudre cette question
la question politique ainsi que d'autres
questions
la situation sur la river orientale de
l'euphrate par exemple nous avons décidé
d'approfondir nos relations nous croyons
qu'une relation avec la russie
ce sont des relations qui ils ne peuvent
pas être
ne peuvent pas disparaître et nous avons
décidé de faire preuve de notre volonté
pour résoudre ce problème
tout d'abord je dois dire que nous
allons respecter le cessez-le-feu
et puis nous allons décider ce qu'il
faudra faire après
aujourd'hui à minuit nous allons
introduire le régime de cessez-le-feu
pour assurer ce régime de cessez-le-feu
à nous allons prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires
notre objectif est de ne pas exacerber
la situation humanitaire dans la région
nous allons faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour aider tous ceux qui en
ont besoin en syrie
en plus nous allons créer les conditions
pour que les réfugiés puissent revenir
leurs foyers ceux qui ont dû quitter
leur qui à cause de ses attaques
nos ministres et des affaires étrangères
à vous présenter notre document notre
texte la turquie quoi qu'elle doit
répondre à en utilisant ses forces à ces
attaques de la part du régime et nous
resterons en contact avec mon
chers amis 1 en ce qui concerne la crise
syrienne
nous allons continuer notre travail nous
allons nous baser sur les principes de
l'intégrité territoriale de ce pays et
se basant sur les accords de sotchi nous
croyons que le seul moyen vous résoudre
ce problème et d'assurer la paix stable
la stabilité dans le cadre des
négociations
merci à tous les dames et les messieurs
sur ordre du président je vous lis le
test qui a été signé aujourd'hui
complémentaires sur la résolution 2
[Musique]
la russie la turquie s'engage à
respecter et le régime de cessez-le-feu
en s'appuyant sur la décision de 4 mai
2018 sur la zone de désescalade dans la
région d'idlib qui a été validé le 17
septembre 2018 c'est le principe de
respect de l'intégrité territoriale et
de la souveraineté de poursuite de la
poursuite de la lutte contre le
terroriste est tel que ça a été validé
par le conseil de sécurité de l'onu le
rétablissement des infrastructures
civiles mais ne pas respecter ce plan ne
peut être justifié par rien donc le le
conflit militaire doit être résolue par
la voie politique avec l'implication de
tous les syriens en accord avec la
résolution 22 54 du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu pour éviter la poursuite et
l'aggravation de la crise humanitaire
pour apporter une aide humanitaire à
l'ensemble de la population syrienne
il faut éviter toute politisation et
tout ultimatum
il faut continuer à agir de façon
danse dans des conditions de sécurité
pour faciliter le retour des réfugiés
pour cela arrêtez tous les conflits dans
la zone de désescalade de ils lèvent à
partir de 0 heure du 6 mars 2020 une
zone de sécurité de 6 km de large et
disposés le long de la route m 4 les
ministères de la défense de russie et de
turquie valide ce processus pendant sept
jours à partir du 15 mars une zone de
sécurité étaient établis aussi le procès
verbal de complémentaire a été rédigé en
trois langues russe turc et anglais à
valeur juridique égale et entre en
vigueur immédiatement
valère le procès verbal 7 septembre 2008
[Musique]
mais je n'ai kaboul et d'eric souris
téléphone * comme une bonne amie jeunes
des lycées la famille assure julien
millet schisme et erin crowe la large
bande à vie les chiffres des regrets ni
consigne il me dit ça et le cas rare et
là où nos 6 à 6 serait toujours eu la
sonnaz et de la villégiale chérèque
il a dit que les indh harada que tu les
chemins sinueux international civil et
lincoln national qui est arabe et une
souris elle est un cochon tout devait
être une 2ème ex usine comme have in
sanilh'art deux salons nationaux qu'elle
a eue kitchen d'un kindle et dean del
rincon s il est muté gilles rnv une
quinzaine d'année difficile en juin avec
une lola rac sourire dès qu'il a sur 10
km
les rennais guérite de niche de nicolaï
erdman 1m mourgues layrac achats des
croustades à moutarde karlstad et les
guérini a d'abord gezin de quitter ma
salle de bains jacques tu as khalifa
radiateur art mari kiviniemi thaïlandais
ça se faisait feu de tout bois
cet objet est qui enders karine
cousineau mais j'ai dû venir de chine et
d'ailleurs à y rentrer et ça c'est aussi
l'aide cultivés à la cnda diguiny chine
de carat l'astre dia h sur route hors
taxes des réalités ombudsman et qui 28
m2 carrés jochen krumbach à inal favori
à cadalen qassimi boeing ghs jacques
yves cousteau qu il nous allons des
andes à une les regrets sur cheyrou
savez english un accord et sidya salle
et celle de jack skille des pêches
maritimes de mitraillettes moscow attack
in the ones
[Musique]
je
on
de ce fait
g
pascoe